[Music]
who was committed to a mental
institution in Switzerland Lottie yes
yes congrats on season two
um I will start with you Christina
because I think both you you Melanie all
of you have been in incredible things
that folks have loved but I feel like
season one was a phenomenon as far as
like how crazy fans got towards the end
of it what was it like for you sort of
watching this slow build of like
excitement week to week because it
really was that for a lot of folks you
know it's been really amazing and
surprising I think you know I don't have
that much experience in TV but I feel
like every time I've done it the whole
thing you're hoping for the first season
is just to be picked up for a second
season so you kind of aren't even
thinking about it being a success on
such a huge level at the same time I was
about to give birth giving birth and
then having a brand new baby at the time
that all this was going on so I maybe
didn't feel it as this really as as
somebody who was able to pay attention
more
um but I have since and it's really very
uh it's kind of just be a little bit
hard to believe like it still hasn't
permeated yeah but it's very exciting
and gratifying and
real happy about it I would imagine and
actually Millie I was there when you
gave your incredible speech of the
critic's choice where I think she could
appreciate this because you thank your
Nanny which I thought was the most
relatable moment in the world I was like
yeah because this is like the best part
of it but your character I will say for
it was so great seeing you in that
moment because I was like oh yeah she's
the mom in real life because you were
the scariest mother ever in season one
legitimately I was like terrified but I
think in season one your character was
so much like trying to hold a window
against the past and keep everything out
and I think you've said like this season
all bets are off like tigers out of the
cage can you elaborate more on where a
shot is this time around and where she's
going well I think it's kind of a
mixture of two things one thing is that
in the fifth season it's the first time
she's allowed herself to feel danger
again and she likes it so this season
she's really like
trying to think of a word that's not
swearing
um
she's sort of pushing boundaries and
seeing what she can get away with and
terms of dangerous activities and then
also
you know you can push things down for a
long time but they're going to come out
somewhere somehow so the season also is
about her you know figuring out her
relationship to her daughter who she is
as a person who she is as a mother and
you know processing all that stuff that
happened before it was the thing I
watched season one that I was most
remarkable about is it's again you just
really appreciate whatever they're not
telling us has affected everyone so
deeply because of where they are but
then we meet your character this season
and it's almost like were they on the
same island I don't know it was in a
very refreshing to see how your
character was adjusting to things
slightly better I guess or approaching
things slightly better maybe that's what
it that's what they've said anyway is
that I mean I think I think her
well-adjustedness is a is a thin veneer
and you know especially as adult man is
drawn back into van is drawn back into
the the these relationships you sort of
start to see what's been going on and
how uh how not okay she is as well so
yeah
um
yeah I don't know I mean it's it's just
this show is so interesting to me to
join uh as a huge fan of it which is
it was just a unique experience to to
get to come and continue the
storytelling and be a part of what comes
next because you know as a fan you're
like what comes next let's come next and
I got to come and be part of what comes
next so so I just have to Quick
follow-up did that mean you got the call
after you were already obsessed it was
like literally always tell me about this
so like they call you and you please
tell me more
I watched the show I was like what's
this show with all these women who I
love and want to see their work and and
then was absolutely obsessed with the
the
the you know the mystery and the
storyline and all of the
wonderful things about the show and then
I
I called up and said hey you want to be
in it yes Christina too with these young
actors
um I do have to say I think they're even
like changing what they're asking of
these young performers I didn't want to
say young but the younger versions of
yourselves is there anything that you
sort of Saw just with the way that
they've sort of adopted the cast this
time and like how they approach filming
is it different from your time did you
guys you both all of you started acting
very young and I've experienced this did
you guys sort of swap stories maybe with
the younger performers any of you like I
don't think we've terrified them with
ourselves
they could have done that with them yet
but um but it is really I will say I
find it really wonderful to see that
that the attitude has changed towards
actors and particularly you know
well they're allowed to set boundaries
themselves they're allowed to be
involved in how the choreography of sex
scenes and set limits and say no to
things and really feel safe and
comfortable and that's wonderful I don't
think you know I wouldn't want people to
have to go through kind of the things
that we had to go through when we were
younger
um so it's and and then also it helps us
because now we also get to say
um what we're comfortable with and set
boundaries for ourselves and not sort of
be subjected to the same sorts of things
that we were you know even 10 15 years
ago so it's a really different time and
it's wonderful and I think you'd have to
be a monster to want to see people
suffer in the same way you did I know
yeah
let us step outside I thought we left it
there and we were rescued
but now I realize we brought it back
with us I have to ask you guys as
viewers watching it you got to see
something that we got to see for the
first time which is your younger
performances so I was just curious as
you were watching the younger
performances going into season two was
there anything that you saw that you
really wanted to kind of key into that
maybe you guys didn't discuss and I'll
start with you Julia I just like
watching Sophie in general because she's
so magical and deep and present
um and I still Marvel at that our voices
are similar at times
but uh we have different paths that the
character takes and I always it's an
energetic thing for me acting so uh my
character is now trying to find truth
and
um meaning to her life and her future
whereas the first season she's trying to
end it so even that energy there's a
shift in um what that feels on a
molecular level I'll get really quantum
physics metaphysical this is the show
for it so like let's be real I feel like
y'all can go anywhere and I'm gonna come
to you quickly this is interesting for
yours but with Tony with your character
too because both of your characters so
driven so everything but what's so
interesting is as your character gets to
see maybe the other sides of that part
of it did you guys discuss how you're
maybe going to show what you have in
your character now your younger self had
but maybe didn't show right um yeah so I
think that um you know we are shadows of
who we were as teen Majors so there's
there's certainly
um character uh
core character things to discuss that
which we thoroughly did during the first
season so the second season wasn't a lot
of discussion I love watching her I
certainly get more from watching her
than she gets from watching me you know
but as far as the character goes like
the real discussion came with this other
taisa and how we were going to present
her and how you know is she feral is she
and even the that other taisa has
changed through the years I mean our
taisa hasn't it hasn't been exposed to
this other time he says in decades so
it's it's it's a new relationship there
too so really I don't I don't copy
anything that Jasmine does
um uh and the character itself was
thoroughly discussed in the first season
so really we're just tweaking things at
this point yeah and then Simone with
your character this little magical you
know thing that we sort of get to really
explore in season two I think what we
found about Lottie is that she's trying
to help people and I know you told spoke
about that and that is some interesting
help I'm just curious if you talked
about about I think that's judgment yeah
because I'm I'm getting people to sign
up today but you know this is this is
somebody that is turning her pain into
help because she's in a way that she's
trying to give back whether it's Landing
or not I'm not sure but yeah
I'm just gonna be very paying attention
to everything I do
um Juliet I also want to talk about
obviously your character delves a lot
into what we talk about with addiction
with a lot what we talk about people
dealing with their traumas but she is
literally just an explosion of things
that can happen at any moment at any
time we never know what her character is
maybe gonna do I loved watching those
impulses it harken back to one of my
favorite performances of yours maybe
Mallory Knox I don't know just that idea
of like you don't know where she's gonna
go how did you guys really sort of key
into those
those impulses that way yeah I think the
writers wanted to utilize that
my the volume I got for my dad no
actually both my parents not that they
were yellers but they both have really
substantial of voices
um but so my point is out the gate it's
really exciting and volatile like you
said and then she turns on a dime and
there's this sort of more quiet self uh
yeah I I couldn't I could barely keep up
with these twists and turns because
they're so they're so vast yeah there's
um it's either like you're 60 miles an
hour or you're idling yeah that's the
two yeah I will say some of my favorite
turns are between you two and I don't
wanna I don't want to give too much away
but if you could really I know I'm
remembering yes I was trying to play her
that she I was losing my mind a little
yeah now I remember because she I used
that a little bit yeah
it's written that she's remembering this
or she's asking her questions but I
wanted to play it a not so logical but
like someone who's mad and confused
about answers that are coming and
they're not in their questions and
someone who's who trying to trust but
deeply does not and so there's also the
Way It Was Written was one way and then
when Juliet and I got to work together
we found different ways and it was
remember there was a few sayings that we
became very intimate and then we kind of
pulled away so it's this this this Force
stormy way yeah I cry about this Misty
babies cry
[Music]
I will say for season two it's kind of a
bit of shock we get to see your adult
version and I will have to say that's
got to be quite flattering like I would
imagine like because like seeing her
I'll be like if that's what y'all like I
literally said that if I turn out like
you I have done everything right it's
the most beautiful the most like
kind-hearted yeah I love her but you
didn't have the same experience as the
other girls knowing in season one
exactly who their counterparts would be
how was that knowing that so much of the
dynamic that she was gonna explore was
kind of hidden again in season one and
what you kind of put down is what she
had to work with yeah I mean I didn't
necessarily think about it during season
one going to season two it has been
intimidating because I was
uh I had a lot of conversations with her
about it being like Oh should I do it
this way and she's like no I'm following
your lead you set it up for me at the
beginning and and then now we make have
this dance together and put everything
in the pot together for Lottie yeah I
think it was kind of nice going into the
first season of establishing Lottie by
myself and just kind of she's a
complicated person and is even just hard
to explain to begin with so
um yeah I think it was a nice kind of
going in the beginning uh I will say
Samantha Misty is Misty no matter what
like there isn't and so it was
interesting seeing Misty's sort of like
worship at what Lottie was doing like
her and Van but I've heard you say that
she's a reluctance worshiper or like she
believes any of it I think she just
fully is like there's power and I'm
going to
do what I can like I you know I I am a
religious spiritual person but I know
growing up in church there would be some
people that like would kind of look
around and then be like oh yeah and then
put their arms in the air and there's
just there's something about that like
oh that's what everybody else is doing
all right I'm gonna do it too so I can
belong and I think that she's
seeing that like there's an opening for
a new place and she wants to belong
there so that she could do something
with it you know I mean that's exactly
right if there's something to be done
Misty will be up in it doing it that is
very true yes funnily enough though it's
crazy to see y'all's dynamic because it
seems like honestly like Shauna Misty's
just doing the things Shawna would do
given like if nobody was watching and so
much of that Dynamic is different
um I have to ask uh you Sophie just
knowing how your adult characters change
going into season two where you guys are
and especially your relationship with
Jackie what were you trying to maybe
explore leading into season two now
knowing how different that relationship
is spoiler alert obviously
I think I kind of was really intrigued
to see process in which seanan will find
her own voice voice in her own path and
will kind of grow into her own I think
she's lived in Jackie's Shadow her
entire life and has kind of just
um molded up to what people wanted her
to be
um and I think she's slowly getting rid
of that
um and and figuring out what she wants
and what she likes and caring for this
baby also and I think
um it's interesting with like present
day Sean I think probably the going back
in the present she's kind of gone back I
mean she's married Jeff she's gone back
to being on the submissive side and I
think she's kind of craving that voice
and that strength that she'd found in
the wilderness and I think that's what
we're seeing with older Sean in the
second season is her kind of cracking
and wanting to be free again
um the showrunners the folks that are
writing all these crazy twists and turns
that have you all going they've said
this is the winter of discontents which
I was like way to make it ominous
what did that mean for y'all because the
added element of winter I know really
didn't maybe hit you guys physically but
it definitely hits your characters as
far as how it changes everything so talk
about how winter switches things up this
season Courtney yeah if you'll start oh
I I mean just coming in in from an
acting standpoint it's a whole different
environment to work in I mean we were in
the middle of
um Forest last year and this year we're
on a sound stage with fake snow and
AC that doesn't get turned on I asked
about that too layers and layers yeah
um but
yeah I think it we find the characters
kind of it almost feels like they've
settled when we find them in the first
episode because
our world has gotten so much smaller
because of the
um
what do you call the one the terrorism
smaller because of the um
because of the environment yeah it's
almost more suffocating for the
characters this year and we're on top of
each other oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah I just think that even the way
that like things are filmed this season
are just so different from last season
last season it was like the plane crash
and we had a lot of handheld camera and
um it was a lot of in your face and like
um Daryl our camera op last year was
like literally one of us is on the floor
he's on the floor with us like he was
really in your face and um it almost
gave you the feeling of like you're one
of the girls trapped here now too
whereas this season it's like you're
getting a glimpse into these people's
lives and it's this Stillness and this
like like this numbness and Serene
violence yes yes there's yeah there's
something so much more dangerous about
this season and there's something about
like the even the coloring of of winter
you know this kind of like bluish vibe
to it but it's like it's so much more
eerie
um this year which is crazy because last
year was just as you know it was already
crazy well stay tuned everyone yeah
hey loves you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yes that's what we want to explore in
season two so you got to explore this in
season two talk about it
um yeah I mean everything just keeps
getting worse for everyone and I feel
like Natalie naturally is pretty lonely
and is far away from the crowd but even
more so this season she's just more
disconnected everyone follows Lottie and
she's just kind of on her own and even
Travis is kind of going with Lottie so
it's difficult
um Liv I have to say everything that you
did in season one is kind of a testament
to your acting but I appreciate it also
because you kind of gave Lauren a job
because they didn't kill you
but that really I mean that's one of the
great little secrets of the behind the
scenes aspect was when did they tell you
like Hey we're gonna keep you around
like we don't want you to I can tell you
when they told me so we uh in 2022 we're
doing like a Woods circuit stuff for the
first season which was very exciting and
like new for me and I loved it but we
were all at the Glad Awards
um and uh Ashley one of the creators of
our show told me at the potty afterwards
she was like we're doing a doll van by
the way oh my God so and I think the
Glad Awards is a pretty appropriate
environment oh my god
um but I didn't I didn't know that uh
that it was gonna be Lauren for a little
while because that they had just started
writing at that point and then I found
out that
um Lauren had said yes uh just before
the Emmys I think so I was just like
walking around him oh wow yeah we are I
already talked to her and she definitely
talked about how she was like such a fan
of the show so like she literally was
like screaming on the phone with her age
it's like of course I'll do it and then
I was like and then you kind of get to
thank Liv for not only being awesome but
being a redhead because of course
epic redhead
of and then Jasmine also say with your
character I mean just watching
the one that's supposed to have it
together right like the one that's
supposed to be the one that's supposed
to deal with it and then watching where
your character is in her adult life was
even more disturbing yeah but so for
going into season two like that was so
much of y'all's Dynamic the put together
person and how they fall apart what is
it gonna be for season two as she sort
of pushes through is that still part of
it or is it she beginning to show this
more of this unraveling I think that
she's beginning to unravel but is having
a hard time with that like I think
that's really out of her control so much
that of her control the elements the
lack of food the lack of
Sunshine because it's winter
is causing to her causing her to unravel
um in a way that I think I'm Tyson's
emotional state is really different this
season like last season she cried one
time and it was when she thought that
she lost a van and this season it's like
I'm like I hope I didn't overdo it
every season Ty's I mean every episode
dice is crying
um but she's just like emotionally
drained and doesn't have the same
capacity to control
her emotions
um and I hope that I hope it works we
don't really know until we see a
mistakes well she was so driven to get
out last season yeah
so the one thing I will say about the
weather is it's the ultimate sort of
Boogeyman this season and it really adds
like a bigger Dynamic to that but I'm
sure that wasn't fun for y'all we we had
to pretend to be called oh so yeah the
whole time of course I would have rather
been in the real Snow to be honest I've
been so bad too yeah I do not like the
face strange doing it in a studio and
having to pretend we would all have to
like before take it it would be like
okay ready and and you're freezing
it's almost like made of paper a lot of
it was paper there was sand did they at
least
no I asked and we have like seven
different layers on really because the
AC is noisy and we're filming and it's a
sound like it'll make sense but if we
had to we would have to remind each
other to pretend to be called I had two
days in Alberta yeah which is just the
coldest place it's where they shot the
Revenant yeah yeah wow
um and we got to see what it was
actually like honestly like my favorite
days yeah like did it now they're
jealous I mean it was just gorgeous I I
wouldn't want to do that for more than
two days yeah this was such a WTF show I
just have to ask out really quick what
was your favorite WTF moment and I will
have to say end of episode two everyone
has said that one but there's so many
other ones there's more but I don't know
I I don't know what um
I'll just leave it at right eight
thousand eight uh yeah well not season
two Not Season Two Season Two eight uh
w2f for sure same yes the finale finale
bunker oh my God the finale I just
remember you forgot about that yeah
do you see
we brought it back with us gentlemen
welcome back hello thank you um Warren
I'm gonna start um with you on this one
because I feel Jeff and your wife y'all
y'all are they're all out in the open
this year but I don't know if that's a
good thing
like I don't know if all the things
on season one or a little bit more out
there does that make it better for their
dynamic or worse I think
uh when we pick up Jeff certainly feels
like there's some positives he can take
out they've aired out their dirty
laundry they've had this confession
Fest where they just had to be them like
reveal themselves to each other and that
can be healthy and in some sick way very
cleansing yeah for them but there's a
lot of bruised ego there too because his
wife is proven she's not satisfied with
him particularly and she's regressing
into this darker manifestation of
herself right before his eyes
so there's a lot going on there project
process and maybe he's not the most
sophisticated
a processor on the planet spoiler alert
he did try to scam his wife
[Music]
um Kevin first of all congratulations on
being a seasoned regular for season two
and I will have to say in a certain way
and I don't want to say this with love
and affection you have to appreciate
that you essentially wrote yourself into
a job by how much everyone hated you in
season one yeah because I know you saw
that but but you have like your
character is just the Testament to your
acting because I'm sure you saw the
tweets and the tick tocks there what was
that like for you it's not always fun
I'm sure no there was something kind of
you know when you know that you don't
need to be liked that's that's kind of
refreshing yeah beautiful way and um you
know the thing I always remind everybody
is uh he's a 17 year old kid in 1996 who
has never been around females very much
and has no idea how to deal with them
and just lost his dad and is stuck there
in a place that he doesn't want to be
the likelihood of making a good decision
is like point zero zero one percent and
so you know I think he's making the best
decisions he can in his place with what
he knows and
that just also happens to be the worst
decision that anyone would get now there
you go
come on it is it's the worst decision to
make like but but he's gonna keep making
them hopefully
uh Steve I have to ask you because Ben
well I hope he's changed his mindset a
little bit going into this season but do
you think he will is that something that
you I don't want to tell too much but I
will just say the decision-making
process of your character is also not
one that folks are really about for a
lot of season one yeah well I mean the
funny thing is I think that I think that
Ben was probably seeing the most clearly
of of anybody in season one but the way
that he was communicating some of those
things probably didn't land all that
well because he tended to be completely
ignored by everybody else you know and
I'm always like if you just if you just
listened to me then you know a lot of
this would probably have not happened
um but I do think we see him go through
a transformation of really having that
realization that he his control and his
power they're just gone yeah um and and
what does that do to a person whose only
identity is that kind of authority
figure when we're when we're out here
once you strip that away
yeah some bad stuff is probably gonna
happen there's so many WTF moments from
this show like just the opening sequence
is one if you can you speak to because a
lot of them you guys didn't film you
guys have very uh focused parts of the
story that you get to see give me your
favorite WTF moment real quick uh I
think the end of episode two is probably
my that's that's mine for sure it like
launches the entire season yeah yeah
it's a good one it's shawna's birth
there we go I stole my answer they stole
your answers they still answers yeah my
mine's definitely especially when I read
it it was the end of episode two
um because I think the timing of it's
just perfect